nos dicen que px es igual a esta
expresión y nos piden graficar todos los
ceros o intersecciones en x del
polinomio en la gráfica interactiva y la
razón por la que dice gráfica
interactiva es porque esta es una imagen
de pantalla de un tipo de ejercicio en
khan academy en donde pueden dar clic en
puntos sobre la gráfica para marcar los
borrarlos o moverlos por eso es una
gráfica interactiva pero esta es sólo
una imagen de pantalla y vamos a dibujar
encima de ella el objetivo es encontrar
cuáles son los ceros de este polinomio y
luego indicar los en la gráfica así que
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
muy bien para encontrar los ceros de un
polinomio tenemos que encontrar aquellos
valores de x que hacen que todo el
polinomio sea igual a 0 otra forma de
pensar en esto es en cuáles valores
hacen que esta ecuación sea verdadera x
a la tercera potencia más x cuadrada
menos 9 x menos 9 igual a 0 la mejor
forma de hacer esto es tratar de
factorizar esta expresión
es un polinomio de tercer grado los
cuales no son siempre sencillos de
factorizar veamos cómo podemos hacerlo
lo primero es buscar si hay algún factor
común a todos los términos y parece que
no lo hay lo siguiente es ver si podemos
factorizar por agrupación y cuando
pienso en la factorización por
agrupación me fijo en los primeros dos
términos y luego me fijo en los últimos
dos términos y me pregunto qué es lo
máximo que puedo factorizar en los
primeros dos términos y que es lo máximo
que puedo factorizar en los últimos dos
términos y ver si hay algo similar
cuando termine de factorizar lo que
quiero decir es que para estos dos
primeros términos tenemos x cuadrada
como factor común por lo que queda x
cuadrada por x + 1 y para los siguientes
dos términos
podemos factorizar un menos 9 y nos
queda menos 9 x x + 1
todo esto funciona muy bien porque si
vemos ahora esto como el primer término
y esto como el segundo término podemos
ver que x + 1 es un factor en ambos así
que lo podemos factorizar
factor izamos el x1 lo que señalamos con
este color si factor izamos x + 1 queda
x + 1 por equis cuadrada menos 9 y esto
va a ser igual a 0 aún no terminamos de
factorizar porque ahora tenemos una
diferencia de cuadrados x cuadrada menos
9 es igual a vamos a escribirlo todo x
más 1 y x cuadrada menos 9 podemos
escribirlo como x + 3 por x 3 y si no
están familiarizados con alguna cosa de
las que estoy escribiendo aquí si no
están familiarizados con la primera
factorización que hice los invito a que
revisen los vídeos de factorización por
agrupación en khan academy y si lo que
acabo de hacer no les resulta familiar
los invito a que revisen las
factorización es de diferencia de
cuadrados pero de cualquier manera todo
esto va a ser igual a cero si tenemos el
producto de varias cosas y es igual a
cero si alguno de estos factores es cero
entonces toda la expresión será igual a
cero aquí tenemos una situación en la
que uno
la solución a esto es hacer que x1 sea
igual a 0 lo que implica que x sea igual
a menos 1 otra solución es lo que hace
que x + 3 sea igual a 0 lo que es x
igual a menos 3 al restar 3 en ambos
lados y otra solución va a ser aquel
valor de x que haga que x menos 3 sea
igual a 0 sumamos 3 en ambos lados y nos
queda x igual a 3 aquí lo tenemos ya
encontramos 3 ceros
si este polinomio es evaluado con
cualquiera de estos valores de x su
resultado va a ser igual a 0
podemos indicarlo aquí en esta gráfica
interactiva en donde vamos a dibujar los
x igual a menos uno está aquí x igual a
menos 3 está por acá y x igual a 3 está
aquí la razón por la que quizá quieran
hacer esto es porque aunque el ejercicio
solo nos pide encontrar y graficar estos
puntos lo que ya hicimos es porque esto
nos puede ayudar a darnos una idea de
cómo es la gráfica de esta expresión
esto nos dice en dónde
la gráfica intersec al eje x por lo que
la gráfica podría ser algo así o podría
hacer algo como esto para saber cómo
sería tendríamos que calcular más
información pero vamos a dejarlo aquí